his voice was full of emotion
and hesitancy as he spoke now a top
diplomat from myanmar has been
fired for what he said less than 24
hours ago kyomotun
urged the united nations to use any
means necessary to end a month-long
military coup in doing that myanmar
state tv
says he betrayed the country let's
remind you of what myanmar's now
sacked u.n ambassador told delegates at
the un general assembly
myanmar military has become the
existential threat
for myanmar as a polity and civilized
society
now is not the time for the
international community to tolerate the
war crimes
and crimes against humanity committed by
myanmar military
the international community must ensure
that
coop has no place in the modern world as
bound by the u.n secretary general
in that regard we the committee
representing chiron surveill
crph julia the united nations
the united nations security council and
international community
that aspired to build peaceful and
civilized global society
to use any means necessary to take
action against the myanmar military
and to provide safety and security for
the people of myanmar
well we'll get the latest on these
developments shortly from
tony cheng in bangkok but first his
report
police in myanmar's southern city of
darwin employing more aggressive tactics
to disperse protesters advancing behind
the cover of their riot shields
they fire tear gas into the crowd
forcing people back into the city's
smaller alleyways
in yangon more aggression too from the
early morning on saturday
security forces occupied areas the
protesters
had claimed as their own charging
forward they pursued protesters
relentlessly throughout the day
those who didn't flee were detained and
not just protesters
several journalists were also arrested
but the mood on the streets remains
defiant behind improvised barricades to
keep the police at bay
and the protesters happy to see their
cause raised so publicly
at the united nations we got so much
encouragement to protest by seeing
myanmar's ambassador to the un
that's why we're protesting with lots of
energy and as much effort as we can have
we feel so
thankful and got so much courage to see
that the un
representative stands with us while
we're trying to protest and get our
state counselor and president released
in myanmar's second city mandalay the
protests were led by monks
in this majority buddhist nation it's
regarded as taboo to attack a member of
the clergy
but myanmar's military has shown in the
past it has no qualms about cracking
down on monks
and it's unlikely these protesters will
find sanctuary
behind their saffron robes
well let's get more now from tony cheng
who's monitoring those developments from
thailand's capital bangkok
tony this sacking of the ambassador
was announced on state television what
reasons
have they given
well uh perhaps unexpected given the the
huge amount of attention
that these statements got both uh
outside myanmar but also particularly
inside and as you heard there from the
protester you know this is really
motivated people today
feeling that their cause has been
brought up before the general assembly
but
the statement read on myanmar state tv
this evening said that as you've
mentioned
the ambassador had betrayed the country
and spoken for an unofficial
organization
which doesn't represent the country and
he's abused the powers
and the responsibilities of an
ambassador well the ambassador did make
it very clear when he got up to speak
in front of the general assembly that he
was representing the civilian government
led by aung san tsuchi
he stressed that they had won the
legitimate
election in november of last year uh
but clearly he's not going to be in that
position for much longer
indeed and tony when he made that that
statement
at the the general assembly certainly
when we spoke with
our diplomatic uh editor uh when that
statement was made
he did say that the ambassador was
taking a massive risk
and it poses questions about his his
wider family
i mean are they coming in for any
reprisals certainly
the ambassador has has lost his job what
about the family themselves
well you could hear the stress he was
under when he gave that address is his
voice cracking as he gave it
clearly under a huge amount of pressure
uh
we i've spoken to some sources inside
yangon today who say
that the extended family are keeping
their heads down but they
do not appear to be targeted but we do
know that myanmar's military has a
history
of using families overseas to
to target people it wants to have
influence over
no more celebrated than aung san tsuchi
herself
whose family or in the uk and for many
years
the military tried to manipulate both
the family
and her to try and step back from the
political stage of something she always
resisted
but clearly they have established a
pattern here and
uh ambassador joel's family are
apparently keeping their heads down at
the moment
okay uh tony cheng they're bringing us
the very latest
uh from bangkok tony thank you very much
in
deeds